رغم العقوبات مشاهدينا يبدو ان الصين وجدت
طريقا للالتفاف على العقوبات الامريكيه
فالولايات المتحده فرضت عقوبات على بيع
اشباه الموصلات للصين الا ان الاخيره وجدت
طريقا للالتفاف على هذه العقوبات مجموعات
الذكاء الاصطناعي الصينيه وجدت الحال في
الخدمات السحابيه للتهرب من ضوابط تصدير
الرقائق الامريكيه فاينشي تايمز نشرت
تقريرا قالت فيه ان بعض الشركات الصينيه
بدات بتاجير الوصول الى رقائق انفيديا اي
مئه في هذه الحاله لا تحتاج الصين الى
الشراء جهاز الكمبيوتر لكنها ستستخدم
جهازا ربما في قاره اخرى عبر الانترنت
يحتوي على هذه الرقائق التي تحتاجها
لتطوير برامجها بالخطوه الالتفافيه هذه
تتمكن الشركات الصينيه من تطوير قدراتها
في مجالات الذكاء الاصطناعي مثل تقنيه
التعرف على الوجوه وغيرها دون فعليا على
الرقائق
نقلت عن خبراء توقعاتهم بان الثغره هذه في
العقوبات ربما تدفع واشنطن لتشديد حصارها
على وصول التقنيه المتقدمه للصين
[موسيقى]
الجميع يعلم ان الصين التي تتحدى الولايات
المتحده بشكل متزايد في عده مجالات تظل
اولويتنا القصوى فالحزب الشيوعي الصيني
يواصل جهوده لتحقيق رؤيه الرئيس الصيني
تشيجينج لفرض الصين قوه بارزه في شرق اسيا
وقوه عظمى على المسرح العالمي على حساب
القوه والنفوذ الامريكيين وذلك عبر
استخدام ادوات حكوميه كامله منسقه لاجبار
جيرانها على الاذعان لمطالبها البريه
والبحريه والجويه بما فيها محاوله فرض
سيادتها على تايوان